so let's play this now
uh i think we should avoid disagreeable
women single moms and feminists and
stuff like that
unhealthy women i mean something like 60
of the north american population is fat
or obese or morbidly obese yeah a dime
she gets fat
she refuses to lose weight for you so
you're essentially paying a pig for the
rest of your life
i don't even know where to begin
y'all this has to be a longer video
because of the extreme content that this
person
posts because this isn't the only video
like this it's the entire account
high value men unhealthy
she won't lose weight for you you're
paying a pig
avoid disagreeable women like never be
challenged
how do you pause oh there you go okay so
you can pause it as it's playing um
so right away you know he's he's
starting with the pointing and
sputtering which is the standard
narrative that you're going to see quite
often
when somebody can't argue the point they
just kind of like make fun of it
or they make fun of you sort of thing um
there's
no response to it yet he's not saying
that you know these are
these are all lies for whatever reason
it's just boom boom boom boom boom so
keep watching this
trigger warning trigger warning there's
more guys i encourage everyone to take a
deep breath before watching the rest
because this is just hyper triggering
no no no no no men and women don't
follow the same rules
i'm asking you the question but of
course there's more
you're gonna get her to download an app
like bumble or tinder she's gonna do
you know women seeking women and then
you have her find the girl right she's
probably gonna find a chick that's gonna
be grosser than her you're gonna have to
whittle it down to something that's
acceptable
acceptable acceptable acceptable for
conor to have a threesome
but wait yeah so you're not allowed to
have standards guys
you're not allowed to do what you want
you're not allowed to put yourself first
you're not allowed to have standards for
yourself you've got to comply
with the feminine first primary soul
shorter that you're lectured upon but
let's keep going
our life coach expert has more for us
here
it's no good girls the only difference
between good girls and bad girls
is the bad girls have been caught the
good girls haven't been caught yet
all women have somewhat of a peppered
past so much worse
but the real kicker is this part a lot
of work that we got to do as god
so where's the lie barrett right like
where's the argument against the point
that is made it's just
there's one thing that i've learned is
that most people just don't care about
and there it was there's the men's
rights when i see content like this
i can guarantee
all right fellas when have i ever talked
about men's rights
mras men's rights activism we need to go
and uh
march on capitol hill and change laws
and all that stuff
i'm the put yourself first guy let it
burn who cares
um i don't care um i'm about controlling
what you can control and i've said that
for a long long time
but automatically what our friend is
trying to do to manufacture drama and
indignation like your typical karen
would is
well let's lean on something that i know
my audience
will respond to so i can get eyeballs on
it
and take it from there so now he's going
down the
mra route which you guys know exactly
what my position is on it
i'm going to find some sort of men's
rights no one cares about white straight
cis manual
okay when did i say white straight cis
men
when men have always been the disposable
sex
women have always been the protected sex
it's always been that way it's always
gonna be that way evolutionary
psychology has arrived at this
conclusion
many many many many many many times over
every single scientific paper that i've
ever gone through always arrives at the
same conclusion
men are disposable women are protected
it is a fact of life it is not something
they get over
angry over is not something worth
protesting over and it's certainly not
something that you'd want to manufacture
indignation over
like this fella is with his trig warning
uh
he actually says up over here we thought
joe rogan was bad
actually i think that's an honor so
thank you barrett for sending me
your audience's eyeballs to follow me
one and two
comparing me to joe rogan thank you very
much i'm i'm actually honored to receive
that
uh level of acknowledgement but let's
carry on
no one this is patriarchy oh here we go
it's the patriarchy's fault it's all the
patriarchy the white cis males
ever been confused of what patriarchy
might be this is it personified in a
person
it is white straight cis men getting
paid to spew garbage
at other people who actually think that
they're doing something
i know there's a bunch of y'all that
follow me that disagree with me and are
just here to troll
but you have to understand that this
human this collective group of like
white straight cis
angry men that don't seek therapy and
counseling but
listen to this are the common problem
this is who we should collectively be
dealing so guys
if if you're following me and you feel
like you need therapy or counseling
um you can find uh barrett pal on
uh patreon he offers life coaching and
he can
certainly counsel and fix you apparently
so the offers on the table in case you
feel like you need it
with not queer people not other women
not men of color like this okay who's
who's talking about queer people or men
of color here
it's this guy again manufacturing
ignatian that
does not exist he's he's not even using
exact wording that i've uh put in clips
that my editor has all put together for
me he's just taking sound bites and then
slapping his crap on top of it his
broken belief system
to cater to the cairns in his audience
it looks like most of the people
following him look like women thanks for
speaking up
and so yeah it's yeah it's it's it's
almost all women that are following this
this guy all of them yeah in fact
anyway let's let's finish this one up
we'll go to the next one this is the
common problem
yes we have issues in all those other
groups but this is the one driving fancy
cars and getting paid to be an ass
i have never felt sick watching
someone's content before
this made me nauseous i feel nauseous
right now
is it clear what patriarchy is yet is it
and we wonder where all these little
boys get all this messaging from
there you go high value man specifically
all right so there's your patriarchy
um lyrics from our buddy single fathers
raise better children
than single mothers if you want to keep
your baby off the ball deep breaths
y'all
deep breaths because of course there's
more who is the bitterness directed too
i think it's just women in general
seeing them for what they are now you
know i had the whole one out
forever and believe the whole disney
bull crap the whole point of the red
pill and
all of this knowledge is not to dislike
women it's
to not dislike them for what they can
never be to you i'm not mad
i'm just what they're forgetting is that
that disney bull crap we were all fed
was fed to us through patriarchy and men
[Laughter]
guys it's always the patriarchy's fault
dude um
i've spoken many times about avoiding
people
inclusive of the unhappy and the unlucky
and that's not something that i made up
myself i learned that from robert
greene's 48 laws of power
law number 10 i believe states avoid the
unhappy and the unlucky
the woke are perpetually
uh unhappy uh they've they've always got
something to be miserable about and if
they don't then they'll manufacture it
uh let's blame the patriarchy and white
cis males you know for example as
this guy likes to do so who they should
be mad
at is the men that have programmed all
of us through patriarchy
but wait there's more women don't care
about men's struggles
there it is all the hurt and all the
pain from patriarchy
not women but women being programmed see
but women being programmed by patriarchy
we live in a female first primary social
order okay
women get far shorter prison sentences
than men for exactly the same crime uh
women have it far easier than men in the
workforce in fact women are
encouraged to enter workforces and
higher paying jobs and are promoted more
often than men
even if the qualification levels are at
a
disparaging uh figure so i mean i could
go write down all of this stuff with you
guys and break it all down i've talked
about it before i'm not going to bore
you with it if you're familiar with
you know with my content you already
know guys like this don't watch it what
they'll do is they're like
well it's you know the middle of june i
haven't put anything out on my tech talk
that has got more than a million views
in a while
let me see what i can put together
that's going to be triggering
uh what does it say over here reply
psa dudes women standing up for
themselves is a effing
amazing and we should stand for that
this heals us too
okay anyway he's talking about uh pain
from patriarchy not women but women
being programmed and paid charges let's
carry on
in patriarchy by men by men
like this and rather than find
counseling and therapy to process their
hurt
they find other men that are hurt you
notice in all of his videos he's talking
about
counseling and therapy because that's
what he sells right
and just bit together dark love it
realize i already embodied a few of the
traits from my five-year day time
approach
why is that important if you have dark
triads
traits that is say psychopathy
narcissism and machiavellianism
then you are likely to be successful
with women because guys with those
traits tend to over
index in the number of promiscuous
lovers that they take
for our collective sanity i'm gonna stop
there with the videos because you just
get the point
they're literally telling you that being
a psychopath and narcissist is a good
thing to score women
also be as disagreeable as possible
because the end goal
is to score women to be a promiscuous
person not to have meaningful emotional
deep connections
which is what these men are craving but
don't even know how to express that
because they've been hurt by someone in
their past
and what men's rights activists keep
forgetting
is that ultimately men's rights exist
within women's rights
so as we heal women and get equality for
all
men will also start to heal oh boy these
men clearly don't understand that space
a relationship around physical
connection
is not actual connection other than
physicality you're not gonna get what
you're craving
through that patriarchy has hurt
straight white cis men as well
all of them included the frustrating
thing behind all
of this is that at the core we agree
that the disney ball
needs to be erased no one's going to
live up to that stuff religious
institutions have fed us a lot of bull
when it comes to marriage it's not men
versus women or women versus men
it's all of us against patriarchy and
the systemic issues
that they bring this collective group of
not the way to be healed i just want to
know why all right
well there you have it fellas the
patriarchy
another one bites the dust as a result
of the patriarchy apparently
you